now there's a second story related to
Fox News host Laura Ingraham that I also
want to talk about we already talked
about the calls for the advertisers to
boycott her show we talked about the
bogus free speech arguments that are
being made but I want to talk about the
defenders of Ingram there are a few
camps who are defending Laura Ingraham
and the first is those who say listen
she said nothing wrong like what she
said
wasn't even offensive the tweet about
David hog was no big deal
okay people can debate that and disagree
about it there are some who are the sort
of free speech people who say someone's
free speech is being violated by calling
for boycotts I already talked about that
that's downright ridiculous there's a
third group that has rallied their
support behind Laura Ingraham and it is
Russia linked Twitter accounts within 48
hours of this incident the hashtag I
stand with Laura GRU twenty-eight
hundred percent on Twitter according to
Hamilton 68 which is a website that
tracks disinformation campaigns in close
to real-time on the Internet the web
site bought check me which tracks
political propaganda BOTS found that
Laura engrams Twitter account and David
Hogg's Twitter account and Fox News's
Twitter accounts were among the top six
Twitter accounts that Russia linked
accounts were tweeting to over 24
intense hours of this campaign on
Twitter an immediate narrow targeting of
these accounts the immediate reaction is
but wait a second why would Russia want
to support Laura Ingraham or Fox News
like is that is that their interest and
the answer is of course no the goal of
these operations is to create chaos and
spread disinformation in the most
divisive way possible so Laura Ingraham
made a comment there was an incident of
activism against Laura Ingraham and Fox
News and Russian BOTS got involved to
escalate the matters by having a counter
online activism insurgency in a target
targeted and automated way this is the
same strategy they used during the Trump
campaign right and yeah part of the
reason for Russia to support Trump's
candidacy is that he's clearly more
manipulable than his Hillary Clinton or
even most of the other Republican
presidential candidates but more general
supporting someone as incompetent as
Trump shows discord it makes people
question whether our electoral system is
working
it makes Republicans some of them
question whether their primary process
is working even our YouTube channel has
been hit by these BOTS not specifically
all Russian BOTS but certainly some
portion of them are and it's pretty
clear particularly on stories where we
talk about Russia if you go in and look
at the comments and you look at the like
dislike ratio yes there are some people
who are genuinely just on the Left who
don't like anytime we talk about Russia
and they will leave negative comments
and they will down both the videos but
they alone are not responsible for what
we see every time we talk about that you
can check it out on our youtube channel
that is the interest here of sowing
discord and generally speaking creating
chaos and it is exactly what we have
seen happen here as a result to the
blowback against Laura Ingraham based on
her comments related to David Hawk send
me your thoughts about that I know
others have also noticed this stuff
happening on our YouTube channel